il porte toujours un nœud papillon et
met en scène son chat tricotine oui
rencontre ce soir avec un maître de
conférence en droit privé qui ne se
prend pas au sérieux il s'appelle
Sébastien canevé il a 64 ans et il vite
à Descartes sa particularité c'est qu'il
réalise des vidéos sur YouTube et qu'il
est suivi par près de 248000 personnes
alors comment expliquer un tel succès
Léa Turquier a mené
l'enquête caméra allumée nœ papillon
ajusté et action Norman classement sans
suite au lieu de faire des vidéos l'an
dernier Norman a fait de la Garde àu
alors que la plupart de ses confrères
ont la trentaine à 64 ans Sébastien est
youtubeur un vrai jeu d'équilibriste
pour trouver le ton juste et adapté à
son public quand on est tout seul c'est
difficile de comprendre les règles du
YouTube game maintenant je je les
comprends depuis que j'ai rencontrer des
collègues mais au début benah on
essayait d'improviser et peut-être
qu'avec un peu de chance ça peut marcher
oui benah apparemment ça a plu ça a plu
et pas qu'un peu sur Youtube la chaîne
vous avez le droit compte près de 245000
abonnés depuis 3 ans le maître de
conférence à l'Université de Poitier
explique le droit simplement en
s'appuyant sur des sujets d'actualité
souvent source de débat expliquer que
que le droit bah c'est aussi quelque
chose qui s'applique de de tous les
jours et qu'on voit toujours la
contrainte queô tué emmerdant du droit
on peut pas faire si on peut pas faire
ça mais c'est d'abord quelque chose qui
nous protège pour rendre le tout
captivant il fallait bien une petite
touche d'humour nous allons téléphoner
au
juriste quoi maintenant là d'abord il
faut lutter contre cette réputation
parfaitement exacte selon laquelle le
droit est quelque chose d'ennuyeux et
donc il faut essayer de le rendre un
petit peu attrayant et comme je dis
toujours c'est pour ça que je mets sauf
exception de l'humour dans chacune de
mes vidéos parce que c'est un petit peu
comme le sucre dans la chanson de Marie
popines ça aide la médecine à couler et
son chat tricotine a très souvent son
mot à dire ce qui est sûr c'est que plus
il y a de vis de procédure et plus les
procédure en bonus depuis le début de
l'année Sébastien est également en live
sur la plateforme de streaming twitch
deux fois par semaine de quoi faire
durer le plaisir en plus de la vidéo
YouTube
hebdomadaire